we started in 20 15 and shouldn't
really give anyone any money is
incredibly difficult finding an apartment in berlin
no salary gets from
islands funny things about the company and we
then lived in apps for two years as the founders
and the money we saved
is honestly not
that real  really motivated we came
from good jobs and somehow got
perspectives that worked why how
can you build a really great company
with a great culture that
builds really good
products that help people that's something great to do who
doesn't know them trade republic will be the
last  here on youtube, massively for their
new brokerage, a bank offered
a trading application of the latest
generation and the boss of it was in the
podcast now over 5 billion
dollars while you just complete half of
Germany stock trading savings plans
who want to know more with
the guy behind wants to get to know
second time in the podcast  the conversation
is coming now welcome to the
podcast second episode with christian
hecker from trade republik i think
two years after we
first met a lot has
happened with you you are one of the
most valuable finally you but your company
is one of the most valuable
startups in germany in  europe almost
to where do we start first of all hello
hello
meanwhile also as a clever
color almost has to say common
format that's why it should
n't be so strong today we
do it together without axel springer
but when we talked now it's
officially here in the podcast  there you were such
a company that was valued at 300
million well i think i for the
rounds he says peter thiel row
came because that's also so yes
so a neo bank one of several
now like the last round 5 billion
dollars 2 so the  best investors in the
world is there this year where
gamestop where everything was like something stocks
in the
the company has gone tenfold since then
they have certainly developed well in many film
metrics so i
think a year ago we were 200
employees today there are 600 you
can already see the largest
one that has taken on and we are sitting in the office
looking at it  out in berlin on the spree
we want you to board a
six-storey building in the office building so that
's really meant to be very sustainable
yes of course we
started in 2015 with the very clear vision
that the pension gap is one of
the biggest problems in society in vienna
we have  they want to solve it and it will
certainly be a ten-year task or
even longer and that is why we are
investing very sustainably in a
location in berlin and want to set up one of the
leading technology companies
here in berlin in germany in
europe that turned banking inside out did you
ever do it when you were in your early 30s  Yes, but
I was afraid of the pension gap because
that was yes i  always such a leitmotif is what
you already have an extremely strong
connection with you so again namely hacker
hears then tells the pension gap
was that you also worry about this very well of
course it’s like that if you were
somehow 26 then it’s not
now rages on  means it consists of getting up
every morning and democracy pension
which was already clear back then,
i believe that the interest rates were 0 and negative
and the question is how can you simply do
something with your money with
your assets in a sustainable way and then
you start with this
deal with the topic and then you see a
lot of numbers, statistics, data and
think oops, actually, this
pension gap is so statistically evident,
predictable, tangible and also so
bad because it will actually
affect everyone in europe that
we have to talk a lot more about it
one of my favorites
I think the most tangible power is if
you turn 18 here in Berlin today, then
e.g  do you pay into the pension fund for 45 years
and afterwards your pension will not be
enough for the rent in prenzlauer berg
yes i think that makes it very
clear that almost every
german will live in poverty in old age if he
doesn’t make private provisions now and if
you just don’t do that  understood
then it might be climate change again a bit
i think i have to
do it a bit too because people
wake up to talk more about it
what do you end up doing about it so what’s going on for
now its the first few days
it’s all a collective term  in the end
you are a simpler monkey bank so
what is the help that he needs
and then first of all the
typical european household can
save 300 euros a month that means fees
are the first biggest
barrier to entry for these people in the
market because  If I pay 10, 20, 30 euros in
fees at the major German
banks, it doesn't make a
difference. You see the money invested  n that means
first of all reducing how
entry barriers that every german
can afford to save
moreover we make it easy today
i still have to click twelve times at a large bank
in a complex behind
counts many numbers it is simply
not a nice experience and we step with
our  public just savings plan
capable people
to make an etf savings plan in three steps the three tabs
and i think that is the product
that our customers also love we
have more savings plans than customers today because
many customers have one two or three
savings plans and that means we  have
today enabled more than a million customers
to really make
provisions themselves is it the current
number of customers that issues more than a
million we were able to increase the number of customers from
last summer that means
more like two i don't know but it has
also always grown strongly have
grown dynamically and  you can
also see how omnipresent it is
this topic is even if we talk to a
lot of people i should also talk to them in the
influence or talk to other
people and then some of them
promote the topic of pension logos they also notice
that the resonance and
the interest in it is very big like
can you earn so much money with it
now namely 5 billion dollars
valuations is above all
priced in hope that is
a normal multiplies because
investors who need
it have given the money the last round
they make the hope for 3 x 4 that
means we have to be
worth 27 billion times one day
so that I
somehow fulfill the hope for everyone involved
even commerzbank the deutsche bank
is not worth that so what can you do what you ca
n't i think first of
all they are no longer worth it to you  were
only once and that is certainly an expression of
the skepticism that these banks are
still able to meet the needs of
f  to really meet the financial needs of
people in 2021 i
think our assessment of the money is
collected the investors is
an expression of how
incredibly strong people believe
that the pension systems in all
european countries are facing a massive
transformation and that
people will make private provisions and
that this is a market where almost every
employee is a potential customer there
are very very few industries very
very few areas where almost every citizen is
a potential customer of yours that
means the opportunity we have in front of
us is really gigantic and
well we  believe the market for a
trading up is boring it is small
competitive does not really provide
value for the customer and your market
cycle the idea of empowering people in the middle of socie
y to build
up wealth and incre
se wealth even in this size of the marke
which allows a lot of
imagination and  that means we still understand
each other in the first
parts so the game is basically kicked
off or are there still 89 minutes ahead of
us what else is to come i
somehow also talked to the first podcast for a long time
about the fact that your
job public is a cool
name  yes also very successful on the
other that you listen then it's
almost a failure because you can't say I'm
not even called trade but it
should be the budget if you public so what
then yes well I'll say I can say I can just
say a name is to be found but
certainly one of the biggest
pains you can have yes well back
then it felt right but yes
still today it still feels right
and as I said today
maybe we are connected to this
pension gap and then we do a lot of
work and whatnot  we actually
want to put it more in the center is the
republic the res
publica the matter of the people what namely the matter how
it should be  e
so it becomes clear to the middle with this idea
what you want to get
at but describes knowing at the time because that was also a
topic again and again in the last few months
how exactly do you earn money with it now where
is there an excess return for you now
so we
started back then in 2015 and  First
of all, he worked together with Commerzbank and
what he learned there at the time
is that banks
and brokers earn money in two ways, one
with fees at night, of course, but also
with
reimbursements  this exchange
directs you get money back a few
cents but you get money back and
so for us the
question actually turned from trainer to audience it
was no longer how can i
earn money without for the customer but
how can i set up a bank that is so
cheap  and efficient in operation is that
can only live with these refunds
but four j  It
also took a little longer than we thought
, but there are today, that means
today when a customer buys a share from us
, when he implements a savings plan
, we earn a few scythes, which
we get from the trading center because
our bank is so cheap and
efficient  we earn money
with it are sustainable and every customer
every trans every transaction of this
trade
leads to a positive contribution margin
and with that you build
a sustainable exciting
business but what is the imagination of the
investors lies in the largest
market it is  in the persuaded
anna as well as the imagination not
that very, very many people invest a
large part of their private assets with us
and the money works for
them and that you then of course
also participate but it's just not
like it is with a google
somehow as a huge company wise not make
30 percent margin because they have such a
one off  solution are somehow but
because i'm just like that the margin
itself won't be that big but the market
for it is huge so i
can say that the fact that we
would have built the bank i now
we are what the costs for the
execution are today  a securities order is
ten times cheaper than the big banks,
which means we already have a very high
margin when it comes to making money from
these few sense of reimbursement
, ok, and at the same time it
has
become a point of discussion in the last few weeks,
this so-called  payment pre-order flow
so the reimbursement another word
for it should
even be deleted in extreme form be
banned because
that would lead
to the reasoning that you earn money at the expense of private investors
yes I think first of
all we expressly welcome this
plan to have more transparency  brings
but there are many myths there are many
misunderstandings  e around these
refunds around topics from there
fled, however, sometimes something in the press
is not quite right
and that’s why I think it’s good that
we’re first of all driven by the
European Commission to
bring transparency and and and more reliability
but we also believe that payment
is required how we use it is only positive
for the end customer so customers
joining the republic trade first on
the stock exchange hamburg is a public
stock exchange this is publicly regulated
there is full transparency every
transaction is published if you are
not satisfied  you can
just contact the stock exchange this stock exchange is
also regulated independently by the senate of
hamburg, so it is not
private and from my point of
view that is a lot of trust
and then a few
weeks ago we published a study that
we commissioned independently
at the whu and that of the pig  s
institute to see how good
the offer is and this study
found out quite clearly that
the prices we
offer our customers to buy
shares are 46 percent better than on the
german reference market setra, that is
one customer  saves 52 cents with us when
1000 euros are invested that has meant
that in the last twelve months our
customers have saved 6 million euros there
are six million
euros more in the German language today
and that is why we see ourselves as
really loud and  Critical voice of the
German saver and we have just been
very strong in Europe in
Germany in politics in the media
for it. The way this
topic advance flow system works for us
is only good for the
customer and we have to be honest and
talk openly about what will happen
if this proposal were to
prevail then at the end of the day the
German kun  de pay more for a web
order he will
get worse prices yes the six million euros
will no longer be there and at the end
of the day the big german
stock exchanges will earn more money and that's what
it is in the end is the winner or
loser maybe from companies like
The Deutsche Börse is important to you because
part of the profit they make
without having to share it with you now flows
through you to your customers, that’s
how you describe it, and the Deutsche
Börse is accordingly less keen because you are a
quasi-monopolist
and suddenly people are there  to have them on the market that are
much cheaper somehow trade
then I'll be there you can say
that the big stock exchange Deutsche Boerse are
quasi monopolies that
are also partly a part of the
Deutsche Börse quasi monopolies
and I think that we have shown
our model the retail  Orders, so to speak,
customer orders have a value and this has
not been remunerated for decades  there advises
investors had to pay very very high fees of
5 euros and more and to have
access to the market at all yes and we
have shown that you can make money with
it that has value and
that is better for the customer if
we can do something about it  worth giving
back to them and yes that's why if you get a
picture on site at the end
of the day it will mean that the customer
pays more has less money in his
pocket and this money just ended up at the big
stock exchange bank it is
then existential for you so who  that's what I want to
come now there's a problem no
frankly not so we have a
wide variety of resources we have
the one euro you pay for the hand
and execution of a trade
we have
areas with the issuers of products
and our
business model is also based on that
less on kevin photo fro more on the
question of whether customers need to save or whether
they need to invest in it and the market
for it like b  said is very, very
big and he
always has a right to exist with companies like trade public it
was
not only positive for you that now the whole
stock exchange shark with gamestop and is a
gambler shares went off like that because
you clearly slipped into it too  in
the communication of the perception okay
now again would sometimes
gamble with yes somehow at short notice and
that's what you do with chf lag was that's
i wouldn't be as gratifying
as you might think
yes i think it was a
positive trend simple
because it i think shows that
culture is becoming relevant for investor capital and
then maybe to get a very brief look at
the internet i think democratized
fell today everyone is their own
publisher they can publish their own opinion
year on year be it on twitter
facebook whatever and it will certainly be
true  we all agree that many of his
opinion may not be without the  most
opinions are but nevertheless it is
actually good from my point of view that
more people are
not able to ask their opinion and just like that
happened in opinion formation i
think it will also happen in the capital market,
namely that access to the capital market will be
democratized that more people will have
access  just have to invest yourself and
yes that will lead to the
capitano becoming more volatile and unpredictable
but i think it is very good that
elites no longer have the privilege of having their
money work for them on the stock exchange
, but that it is precisely this ability that allows
their passive income
also now earning the middle of
society
we know that currently brought customers here
so you want to get this message
out you have a million
plus customers where do they come from so far so
how do you find yourselves
so first of all in germany
we really enjoy sustained popularity
and are growing  still dynamic just for the sake of
being who we are  there are also perspectives to be found
in germany there are 80 million
people of whom ten million
people are just
starting to invest their money in shares even our one
million customers still seem small compared to the
ten million yes
and beyond that there are many, many,
many people  who have never
invested before 50 percent of our customers
are just investors who have
never owned shares before these people find
us mainly via google yes they
just look more or less that is the first step
the first way to invest money what do
i do with a savings account
then performance marketing is finished, so to speak,
or or it ea at google with the
change from yunus channel exactly how
you see it yes on the one hand
i think growing above all
organically wanted to regulate
it in many
circles of friends today too  we're starting
to create try
republic out that we're sort of the name and
the gesi  cht for this movement are
to let money work for you leads to the
fact that people are very active
themselves you also do such a very funny
action so now somehow
i think over christmas made somehow
a recommend marketing for someone
there is the wii 2  euros in
shares in the portfolio, however, you can
choose the shares yourself
, you either have to draw them or
something like that, but you pay 200 euros as a
reference for new customers, yes, that's
what I have to do as a
catholic
münsterland small parts died or so
pronounced so motto christmas
or or mary kripo it was a
ten-day campaign where customers just
got a bitcoin
simply because we believe that the best
present for christmas is the future
and that's good for people
to put the first investment in their portfolio
and but that's it  cool action so
today you can
buy a share for up to 200 euros from third public b  we
get less when someone
recommends something new everyone has so every customer at
the publisher has a shareholder has
i think this is very, very deeply rooted in
our mission that we make almost every
customer register as a shareholder
you are a shareholder if you shake hands with
us and then  you get really
future-proof
stocks and put good stocks in the rest of the portfolio these are
really the 10 15 big companies that
you can imagine so you can
then have apple
have facebook have popular elections it's
always kind of good blue chip
stocks
given away we just give you as a
trust that you start
investing your money yourself how much
there are afraid of contact many people
say whether every word the british shares
and if you give the people a first
share and they have to sell it first
but that was it  there you
have the first order how much do
the average customers have we e  Also in
your portfolio area you were 10,000 euros
5,000 100,000 that the
average portfolio wasn’t
always nice it is difficult for
customers to use Sparta, i.e. you start with
the 500 maybe with 1000 euros and
then you really
pay 34 500 600 every month  euros and
then build it up over time, that
means a lot of people have
more than 10,000 euros with us and when you
see that we have a lot of
young customers in particular, then you
can say they have a large part of their
assets with third parties today  project but
there is also something like
the whales who have 100,000 river there
are also plenty of them I realize I think
we are a cross section of
society we have customers from all age groups and
all wealth and income
brackets and there are also customers who are a
bit larger  manage or they are
happy too okay and now
get customers so search engine talked a
bit about
what we are looking at right now digital marketing
area sees crypto companies
advertising yes me everywhere so of course there are
dot com
scripts the staples center has a lady who pays 700 million
for ten years to be there like
the namesake when you go to a
football stadium no matter where  spain
england germany perimeter advertising everything
any trading apps any
structure companies what i do
n't like so intensively with you if i don't
yes we are really organic so we
are still in the market phase where it's all about building
a brand by the people
for the people and  let me say the
big brand building measures that
the many big banks are still making
don't
mean they're coming because they're sponsoring borussia
dortmund, for example, that's actually not an option for us
and not feasible and we
tend to really trust
that word team  that's branding
but what's more is to all
people than he is around here in berlin
I think the old forester's house, the closest thing to the
public arena, would be doable yes and
certainly also kind of exciting and
maybe a bit funny on
the other hand, we mainly
rely on digital scalable measurable for
youtube I always feel like I'm there
when I'm looking  still
looks inside so I guess
I'll probably have the third channel
at least for ecological
reasons wastage yes but I get yes
tell me again see what the economists team is there
yes so we really play all the
digital channels
be it youtubes now it's called
instagram above all  are you growing organically
is currently so in the industry that my
observation i started start is how
we not only have trading up should also
corrupt companies that is hardly
distinguishable really so
after my observation of the willow long
there was a kind of unbundling  where everyone has their
own thing than that that has always
done so a tradin  g up group b
company or crypto purchase platform
whatever and now everything is growing would
say there is always so
the next evolutionary stage bands
located serve all these
functions or so now all of a
sudden you are also directly opposed
to companies that used to just
couldn't have done and that we are
now a competitor with you that brought the
right one it's
certainly true that now the
asset classes all diverge a bit
everything somehow grows together on the
one hand I think it has to
be said again that the cultural
difference between a  hamlet and on
the coop trading platform and what
we do namely building up lasting, exciting
connections but it is very big
today we are the
only bafin regulated provider in germany equipped with a banking
license
that offers both shares and club boss we
only recently  Krupp just started the savings plans
in crypt  ic is
that you can now somehow sustainably
invest 10 1500 euros free of charge
and that where we see each other that
means although I think
it grows a lot together that he grows together in the trading area
maybe also in the gaming
area and where we see each other in
I think the spa area is just a
bit separate from that how many
trading apps are there in europe I
would have said 30 40 50 what exactly there
are many meanwhile it has of
course become
clear where the market shares are
distributed and
yes I have  it was good that many
people are now offering free
access via simple apps that will
only help to
democratize access today,
85 percent of germany would still not be on the
capital market so welcome if
really every player and every
competitor on the market will  also
only lead to
more people investing their money and gi at the end of the day  bt
one should consolidate that you
then somehow start so clear the
small apps and their customers quasi and
emerge i personally believe we
will he less anemia eia but
this acquisition of companies and want to
grow more organically from our own innovations but certainly a
lot of market  a lot of money has flowed into the
market a lot has been done and
your husband will certainly come to
a phase where he will do it again but now
you have a feeling for how much should
be across europe how much that
should be
trading cards in the broadest sense  times yes i
have the biggest there are maybe ten
i just think there are more but
now with relevant size and price then
somehow with 100,000 customers well ok and
mine talks about saving and investing money for
them for the old and at the same time
also krupp that means you are
obvious  is the thing to
figure out was strong belieber
instructors and bitcoin says there  s also
makes sense as a pension plan where he
probably has a lot of orders which if
we look after pension plan totally
crazy what makes you sure the
bitcoin in the long term mostly or other
christ so first of all since we
started we weren’t always so bullish
what gordon is going on we met relatively
late  It started in the summer of last
year
and the reason for this is actually that
we are seeing that crypto or some
currencies in the course area of bitcoin holid
ys are now becoming estab
ished and respected class
s. This can be seen above all from the fact
hat more assets are now held in bitco
n by institutional inves
ors  we that private investors that
means pension funds pension funds
of teachers in america the
leagues can now also get their money in terms of currencies
when we talk about the pension gap we are actually talking about
three things we are talking about
demographic change and the
inability of the government to
adapt this pension system  we are talking about
structural 0 and negative interest rates and the
inability of the ecb to really approve the interest rate market
and we are now talking
about between very very strong
inflation demand that the latter
worries me personally and i think that crypto currencies, especially
the major currencies, are a good  match
so a diversification is for
investors to also avoid these risks
when it matters and i think
that a very large sustainable
market is emerging and i think we are
well advised to give people here in
germany the chance to participate at an early stage
not that in ten years
when it's actually clear and how
it is everyone says we'll have something
bitcoin probably smells more like that in the next two years 100,000
actually such predictions are always
difficult but i believe the concept of
money being kept independently
whose from the euro and I have that from
d  en from the state fiat
systems, I think that's very
strong, more so than the new gold,
maybe yes, we have a very
strong brand, so yes, not yet like
golder, almost like gollia, you're very
frustrated, I know how you could have  you are
also very left in politics
there is a different view, so if
you now have such theses, there
are still a lot of doubts here in political circles,
yes, if you have to say, of course, that
if you propagate the same thing as I
just said, then  first of
all, when you have pensions, you have doubts about politics
and the ability of politics to
turn things around in some topics, so
i can understand the aversion
, so that's really
a bit surprising, that's the topic in
the federal election campaign
gap in pensions the subject of old-age provision is
one where everyone has played a role
and I have to say quite clearly that I am
now trying to be a subject and really  after
climate change, in my view, this is the
biggest social problem that
affects everyone that we have here in
germany, so we are all the
happier, but that the new
government is now taking
a first step with the share pension, a
small push of the leash  under pressure from the
fdp, i think that yes, i
think many also in the last one, the spd
and the green ones are also worn, but
that there is a change in thinking
, we have to do something now,
small steps, tripping step, but
we are going there and i think
That's a huge success and
Scholz's statement that the pension is actually
certain, so that he's more or less
like Norbert Blüm back
then, then you must be more skeptical, so
you can certainly say that
the pension is secure in the short term
, but you also have to say that the
Federal Republic wanted it  Germany spends a large part of
its economic
output on making the pension system
work  ren that is no longer wearing
off that you have to say very clearly
2025 to 2030 even a baby
boomer will retire then the
system will tilt exponentially because then
many, many more people will leave the
system and just
retire and  there are independent and
multiple studies that very clearly
calculate that there will be a gigantic
pension gap in the future, which will then
no longer
be able to be functioned by taxes and i think
that's why we have to talk very openly and
honestly about the fact that we are
here  full throttle driving a problem
similar to the kindle you can calculate it well
but still it is a
bit pressing the problem with climate change
is yes it is so elusive so
we would be telling wifi today that you will have
a problem in 30 years that's okay
one problem that really
encourages me is that we have on friday
future so today we have people,
especially young people who  don't say so
anymore there is some political
class has ignored this problem a little bit
for years decades
we should have started with certain measures in the 90s and
we even have to talk now and these
customers who are public through third parties who
are actively investing their money today  who
organize themselves who also listen to the podcast
that shows me very clearly that the problem is
gaining in importance and
maybe at some point we will have an event in the
future where people will take to the
streets and say hey let's talk and thus the
pension
will be up to date to say  or strongest
competitor with what they do the
piggy bank 85 percent of german
money not on the capital market so
that sounds like a funny
answer others know is just as well
if that changes but only the
mood is more and more people investing money
then it is  market gigantic
and then there is space for several trade
publics in this market our german
b  ank don't
say for sure if it's about it's
somehow attractive cheap that its
bridge to address are more the
other fynn tags than now the big
classic who do you
reckon with that so will kux scalable or how does it look
so
sure there are many there global
good market  do or do a good job
be it a revolution 26 there would be
but
frankly they really
all invest in
creating attention and that's
the most important thing for me that's
why we see them of course as
competitors but also in many places as
allies and of course it gets on my nerves
that it  a company that we
would also compare robin hood is the
american portal is something
different but in the end it has to have a similar approach to yours
on the road in many aspects
and they went
public a few months ago with a value of 30 billion
now to come  half so
no success story not
so much anymore  worth at all than you
now in the last round that
you also push your partners down there almost a
bit so that is a
problem i think there is a good ds on
the stock exchange and that the
numbers are public and yes me
I think these numbers make it very
clear and open where the differences
are I think on paper
the offer from robin hood and the
European neo brokers looks similar
if it is a public agency
it is very different maybe very
briefly if  you take a step back
and compare the markets many people in america
don't know that the so-called
forward program with the on-site
program every american
employee saves on the capital market
it just happens automatically that means
the american investor isn't really worried about saving, he
just wants to  only own individual stocks maybe
want to bet
sometimes maybe just a little bit  that
you earn money robin
dutt has certainly decided outstandingly
and then totally great offer says this
gaming solution maybe that's just
fun to invest in it is cheap if
we go to europe it's exactly the
other way around as a horde of cfd
providers offer binary options
Whatever they make short-term gambling
very easy for us, we've been waiting for
years, yes, that was never really
an area that was 1 1 1 1 interesting,
but we've talked a lot about it now,
that saving is the big
problem and that's what we offer with
trader public and that led to
us having a completely different market with the bike the
problem here is that our
customers receive a completely different one like
I said we have boring investors we
have people who make savings plans and serve them
monthly that is very, very
far away from Germans  or or or
gamestop and so you can now
see the metrics at robert that he
when the market  is going through the roof
are gigantic like last year
in the summer but if it was
maybe a little less dynamic like in the last few months
then collapse
and there is red public I should the
numbers be completely detached from and
that's why it's not now  What is really of
great overarching importance is
, so to speak, the interest rate policy of important
opponents or a topic for you, because if
we raise interest rates again, that it will be
discussed, then of course there are
other investment options
also
happened the the shares that are
shown for you buy shares that
will be beaten if we immediately or
as soon as the interest rates go up then
that's bad for saxony we
've experienced the last few weeks so you're sitting there
you think shitty rise in interest rates how that
costs twice no honestly  so not at all,
so the editors always have to
do a little bit  en we
are currently talking about interest rates being
raised to perhaps 0.5
basis points america i have in europe
we are so important they pay very very
far from the fact that this is
even politically possible and that is
not a real solution for anyone out there
problems we're talking about it 6 78
percent that i need to really
build up wealth that's why i think it
's good if you moderate them a
bit and if a bit
i would say also takes the steam and this
air out of the market the last
two years have for that
we deal too much with macroeconomic
figures to believe that things could
go on like this now and i think that
we have two really wild years,
terrible years with corona with cupid
and i think it's good and important
that we say something about the kroner phase  often
not slowly coming out that
interest rate policy is calming down that
inflation is going down again this
e  just have a stable
macroeconomic environment yes
as far as i think stocks yes that is
certainly just a a little
correction but i can tell everyone the
second dot com bubble is conjuring up from
my point of view the earnings are the
gains the the development of all
the white people  tech companies that contradict about that
sustainably that are breaking
record after record after record after
record there are really big trends
behind digitization and that
will prevail regardless of
short-term market
cycles  no it's
really not so natural
you notice a game stop or
other short things but seen that
year it's really true relatively
independent of the stock market yes there is
a strong and a weak month but
that develops relatively dynamically and
sustainably  what are currently your
next wich  most countries after germany
for the first time in 2021 the team really did a
great job we started
five markets despite corona and growth
france spain italy
netherlands austria
that means a year ago if we had
talked we would have served 80 million
people in germany
today it is almost 300  millions of all these
markets that is a huge achievement and
today we are also java bad biggest
broker in
france and in spain where we where we
started between
legally wraps so this
problem will be talked about all the
time it is in all markets but then
i got it  also local players so yes if you are
very frightened and then you
may have to talk positively how much
more expensive and sometimes worse
foreign banks are willing to deal with the
German banks like here
the big broker online broker good offer also on the
dirt road behaves like you
compares favorably with French
and Spanish  ic broker it costs
50 euros to buy an apple share in
france that's the whole thing so only the purchase
fees is have yes and is and the
offer doesn't really feel
up-to-date so it's
annoying and I think there are too  no
French quarters publics who are
already serving
that republic so not yet now
we exist and then the French would have to land or
ok and that's also
relaxing there there isn't know that
there's a football stadium there now and there's
a gang of gangs everywhere ok so
handicaps are obviously there and that
's a difference not so we introduced the
concept of the savings plan as well as the one in
germany
in cheeky spain it didn't exist like that
and it's certainly a bit of
explaining work but when people get
the concept what's so easy for them first
have understood then he starts the
same machine as
you do in germany too
again with
search engine advertising probably
price comparisons i just
heard that they then somehow tried
to address french stock depot price comparison sites
then something like that
exactly i think first of
all it's about
bringing the product onto the market
to test it that works because
you have to  lots of little tripping steps go a
lot of testing a lot of isolating to
first get a medal or
customers the fans will be of the product
and then you can continue from there
but we're certainly still there
in the first steps in these
markets how much money  There are more so
currently months in general for marketing
of the order of millions yes
certainly increased significantly from
one year but as I said if you
grow a lot organically so if the customers
really come here it is
less big one assumes
but as you know you want to pay  always made us feel
like
it was mei now  ne next question
we won't rest podcast or the
sales question i know it will be difficult for you
but it's already over 100
million yes
first class he really dynamic and
then we don't execute among fans
okay but it sounds the same as
usual  a lot of money now a bow
about the last round he's
public there came how much money came in
than dollars higher than the receivers
a total of nine million dollars yes first of all
the saying went in the
company that means it could
hold out for a while  so much money
can it be invested in a few weeks well
certainly it is so that this round of
financing and turns off
really very very sustainably again
it is big to invest so we
are currently
looking really globally for executives
for great people who want to  we
're really coming to help
build a technology company here and
that's not a strict rule  h this way that's
what there you will have good phases
if we have now then
maybe sometimes you will also
have difficult phases that may still come because
i'm already behind us and
the most important constant is simply
that the best people are the best
employees get what you
talk to people a quick but that
interests me at the time
international expansions that alone
everything via the hamburg stock exchange so
if someone in france
then buys a french company then they bought it
via the hamburg stock exchange exactly we apply it
the way we do  if
Germany apply and act German
bank license because the customers are all
ecm location Germany and they are
all shares available so I am
French disabled there are a
lot of French companies then they
all have a few foil or
could still be the partly harsh there
so we are in very close contact with
the stock exchange so that you can now  t actually
all relevant stocks are available in these markets
that we are
and that is of course also white
im brings into day-to-day business yes is in the
french or in general but so
buying stocks is still strong
international business so buy
german german stocks and
american way know or  and
french correspond to french and
american you can
imagine
i think that if you think a lot
the idea that investing and saving and
banks is generally very local what i can
already see is that people 30 are
international music from countries with flex
or they buy it  the big titles as well
as the 30-year-olds here in germany
and i think they suit
them an international movement ok that
means having a french company
on it i don't think you need it
at all because i don't have that
much demand for it in europe  exactly yes
but although we have them but we also
want them all  investors probably still
have people over 40 or 50 but i
think the trend is towards
these 40 50 60 global companies
interested in dialogue and in addition to the
hamburg stock exchange there is another
player who belatedly long & black
describes what if  he himself
is also listed on the stock exchange and already
independent but there you are now
but I think the most important partner of all
we are very happy that we met with long &
black back
then but disappeared as a sponsor in the stock market
game back then so the connection came from back then
no today is natural
a very important partner for us
who sort of handles
and executes the business and what does it mean
but also works together in many neo
brokers that I'm the
republic now no no no why
couldn't I do it myself so why were
you what they do something for you but
could be the only
stock trader took listing and and make
the market and the quality  it's
a very highly complex product, which she
says now, but I've been offering it for twenty
years with a great deal of know-how
and the material public is always
well advised and
fixed on the real channel,
so to speak, I take the best, simplest, first the
cheapest app  offer for the customer
and that I think you are really
well advised to do according to at the
beginning the sponsors of the stock market game were where
you are so well we and should
n’t nobody wanted to invest we
didn’t have held 60 investor
meetings there on a typical one
to come so that after the
first one is already over
and then the next thing we
need is an nlp is a product that
people somehow use that but
thomas marco not in a small
standing apartment christmas 2015 and
then we have the two of them i can do
that  yes, not
over christmas the first prototype of
treffer just got built and
then we needed l  i got data for the
soccer games and we didn't get them
anywhere either and then at some point
rittermahl at lang & schwarz said the idea they
're open maybe live then
quietly admit it and then they gave us that
and that's how the first contact came
between you meanwhile when you
call  then go straight to it
wanted that is relatively business or that is
probably about you can also extrapolate your
numbers a bit based on
the long and black numbers
you can see what you have for the sale
so or your volume so that's it
now  no one would have
and probably even worse
that you would have become so relevant yes
I certainly did but that you all
expected
to bring them back okay okay and then
tell 600 people now and if
you follow that then
people from planners will come from  netflix
so you reinhold here how's it going
you write a link to the people then
you tell the person you b  is
the material big here now at netflix you do
n't have to come to berlin and then
he says we're going to get tight
again
so first of all what's really already
here in germany and
europe i think you have to say quite frankly
that it really isn't there  there are so
many unbelievably many people who have seen a large
technology company adscale for
five six seven years and that
means we are dependent
on
winning over global executives who then come to us in the
engineering data processing area,
be it in the marketing book and
always help us there  of course the
investors also have is also experienced
that from peter thiele excel csv and we
also have these investors
because they probably have one of the
best networks worldwide and
especially for the children valley and
you get a feeling for which
employees stand out  also the
companies who could
imagine something like that  just go to europe
and then a
process that usually lasts 6 to 9 months begins
where you meet and invite the family
to come to berlin where
you show them here where you
talk a lot about the mission
about our culture about what
we want to achieve and yes today we
certainly won six seven eight people
from netflix from Gesang from bmw
from uba from streiff who
then really moved over with kith and kin, as the
saying goes, and are now here
with us  build something up and then you have
to but before the interview i
told myself how to make your own personal
berlin weekend with that then
the area would be a sign of
which villas we can buy we
don’t want to have yes so i’m with
you now too  already told
two things that the that keep coming back
people always think that in berlin
is just as expensive as los angeles and
if you have the feeling back then  there is what
you somehow get innkanal and grunewald for
an apartment or in prenzlauer
berg then the expected ones come in a
different way and then
people notice that you can be
satisfied with less here, that means
you still have to send millions of packages
very quickly  i want to be paid well is then well
but he we are not there yet
that we are now in silicon valley
as far as remuneration is concerned and another
topic that almost everyone has
addressed in unison is that everyone is fascinated
that the children can go to school on their own
so that  the topic of security,
social coherence and and just like that, yes,
all these advantages that Germans
also have, you have to say that
fascinates many people,
the great reliability,
security, even in the city, is ok and
then it's ok anyway out of ten calls
you can convert one  to come to berlin
yes it's more like that you have
fewer conversations but they  take a very
long time and because you also have to
build up a lot of trust because it
's a huge cult band, of
course, to pack your bags at netflix in
los angeles and then just move over the table
to berlin for the small,
modest training session so it looks good
but that's how it is  writes it’s getting
bigger now and what’s noticeable is you still
believe very strongly in
offices, so the boarding passes big
office buildings deliberately draw people to
berlin, they could also
work somewhere else, of course, but
that’s not the thing,
so of course more people
enable them to work freely and
flexibly and home office will also
be an integral part of us after
kona yes on the other side
believe that just
meeting anna coffee machines and
thinking about talking is a big part of the
fun with something like that  the
third public to be there and just with
the office
have that to the backyard her  In
Kreuzberg there isn’t really a campus
that’s really being created and we just want to
create a lot of offers that employees
like and often also commercially it’s
generally the case in our quarter now that
we’re now merging with the
former East it’s going to be a
bit of a hit right now
I think  i have three or four or five
companies so how
do you pack
20 to cover hella flush too and
now otto bock is
somehow building a building and if
you do it all like that then there will now be
60 70 billion market cap or
goodwill of the but one  blog that
's more than some small towns that's
how it turned out it's
really crazy i think what's happening in
berlin and we
've been here in the city for five years now in the
ecosystem that's really
gigantic can also be seen in the  many
rounds of financing the many if all better the people and the talent is getting better but you also have to  h unfortunately always
say things are going well elsewhere things are
still going better
so the round of financing in
germany has increased but
has still increased even more in america in
england so there is still a
lot of catching up to do for us here to continue
investing on the other hand if
i now watch the founders of
this monster company also gorillas and
so you read shortly after the big
financing rounds that they
start doing things themselves as
angels so then they
obviously not only made a capital increase
and money the company reinhold die
most of you took a bit of
your own money off the table with you
that you invest somewhere or you as a
green team i read we
are really from ups are focused
appearances
panasonic we believe that focus is
crucial and again very
strong  appear public and that the
value will be created above all
in  in the future yes that means
you don't really have as much as yet so there's
a bit of a chance no we've been
warned republic
so I can do that now that you
with such a fat
round they'll even get through it  almost
had to say man I
was even more shares have
already sold a little something no that
motivated us so I think we
already talked about how we
started 20 15 and really shouldn’t
give anyone money is incredibly difficult in
berlin  finding an apartment also does
n’t get a salary from his company in syracuse
and
we then lived in apps as founders for two years
spent the
money we saved honestly never
really motivated us we came from
good jobs with some perspectives
that worked why how  can it build a
really cool company with a
cool culture that really needs a good
product?  s people help is
what you should do in life yes awesome
that means you are there I still want to have
somehow changed the level, so to speak,
handshake is clear content
but otherwise you don’t do so
much no I was listening again in the
meantime  drive now so no
luxury to to to the office but doesn't
remember much there are big numbers
but at the end of the day it's about
investing this money
that's my money making more money that's more about
the money hiring people
to build infrastructure
you can build up a brand here
and work with the best picture
investors and they
also want to see
what the founders
say  have
so that at the moment stays more aggressive so that
it stays tidy like so sometimes it's
not just that you have the
area so it's negative  being
aware of the goal people give the
founders a bit of money so
that they can continue to work in peace that the
focus is even better than if you
always worry a bit
different models and and the
people do it the way they want
but
one  wish it's really about
now here in this money and these
customers and investors really a
great company often was i would have
thought that you were now also
studying art history so now
with johann könig the gallery
that's the same for you then the
work rhythm is the seven  days a
week or
so if you have an internet company
that is growing so dynamically then
the boundaries
between life and work
are just blurring but if you have been working towards it for 34 years in a
quiet room
every day is really
bigger it really makes me very happy and
it  makes a lot of fun
we have grown very dynamically before christmas
that was really
really difficult had
to go the christmas break if you
want it goes even
further he is the best phase
growth in the area always like that at the beginning of the
year people were mostly
crucial is of course of course also
earning the vacation then really have
too  with the with the minsk plump
shapes everyone has stayed healthy and
alert but each other it
really is more fun every day that they
are doing it and if you just
look at it again such an office is being created and
then soon they will all move in then it is
really more  reward than anything else for
and abolished there you are also extremely
close and yesterday like because they
regularly come over and check which table
coatings are correct otherwise what so
my brand would like to build up I do
believe that it is important it
creates my experience and that starts with
velcom package if you are an
employee with an employee card with
a workplace up to the
product and the brand and yes we do take care
that the
office but also the public brand can
be found there and that the expression for
the existence is a
premium product with values that are sustainable high quality funct
onal intuitive you have to feel that at work too
at gartner there are only a
few premium products you say at the same time
for a very broad mass so
we haven't managed that many of them
this balancing act towards either you're
just all the others you'll soon be mass
or you're just somehow not
mercedes or audi or  porsche then
you're just a little more water until the
premiere i think that's exactly the
raison d'être technology
technologies from my point of view create
price premium disruption they offer a
better product for a cheaper
price that's exactly these
economies of scale that always
exist, for example  about black when there
was actually just his private
driver un  d sedan yes with
drawbacks and so the criticism but
still it was kind of a service
and that was lux is who previously only had the
elite and do exactly the
same thing we also offer today very
self-confidently
a better product than the established
banks in a nicer one  outfits for
less cost and that's
what matters what do you think how big
can belong so if you now have something like
that because the hope also personally
have heard ratings now 20 30
billion it should be by now
it sounds crazy because there are
quite  few German companies themselves
are worth that much so if you take a
look we would probably only
look at the dax look there and not even there they
are all somehow worth 30 billion
so you are the top 30 company from
Germany in the end if it all works
out yes we  we also hope that
the germans will continue to develop
and here we are already 30 a day the
companies and they are growing  really
going strong and i think
take public right now there is a whole
other series of totally great tech
companies that do jobs here afterward
so i think there
is a good future ahead but yes you
have to say that as i said the
pension gap is individual  largest company
one problem is the assets we have in
europe is one of the largest and
if you provide a solution
for it the imagination is already there
that is a very important
company can become for millions
of people and you will notice that it is also a
competitor  is good again
and on the other hand so I'm
also set stallone is for example
the one you don't even know you know
yourself because you're there people are also
losing that's one of the few is
the apparently as well as cold market
phase we too have the same talents  put on
we manage to get yes and the two
founders of zooplus and i slept in my
bed  to a seminar in
munich don't forget yes
thought what you get
no there are 10 - but also
other really great companies here
now a duck there are of
course other fresh air euros in
turkey anyway all of which stand out
you feel  also all so equally
the hearing because I'm therefore like
I said somehow it's already like that
after a round of
financing if you've got
it so quick it's that hot [ __ ] then
you're a bit outstanding
especially high dynamics and agility yes
me  I always have it in this phase
like that, you mean the
build-up phase when you need these
56,789 people right now and there are companies
that are also in this
phase and with whom we do
n’t look left and right who are
in the  to take management ranks with those
mentioned, they are really
all wrong people who are
doing a very good job and I think
if you just
let them do it for a few years then
something very good will come out of it
where did the investors come from in the end what
you just described you, by the way,
he is now used to you with
ladders but still there is
probably even in germany with
all the growth there is no company that has such
an exquisite cap table so
now tcw is well known excel is the
best known choir is maybe the
best ever then peter
thiel how did they all come about so
i will put the thing together this way
and tilted it  that your petacchi who was
already in there before his
network somehow called together
actually that's really hot or how
come
yes I think that of course always
when you look at it at the end it just
seems like it's just described
because there really wasn't one in the master plan for
us  it was always important
to have two things investors who support
this vision sustainably and for a long time, like
me  n yes someday say sit down
come another training
session will we make a lot of money out of it so far
and secondly people who
really have the best possible network
and logically build up a company we
were very happy then excel &
founders found itself in the city  got
what we had back then and
somehow forgot
about the project well, well, even if johanna horstmann were there
very early on too,
the topic with the network
others, like I said, nobody wanted us for a very long time
then we were
very lucky  a long process to have
the first real investors with clothes and products
,
then you need a slow, small network that breaks out.
american
investors are now also
looking for investments here in europe,
yes, and then you
sit at the table in angeles  and then of
course you get excel fans found stamps to a
certain
extent and we  nn you then
develop dynamically the numbers
fit then at some point there will be
a win was you 3
and and would also like to invest
and we are even happy about it has it
together with these although both had to with
pretty then yes want club then
see that we want  yes and i
would say the best investors are
still very present is
so no it is not like that so
you always have to go there and
explain very clearly what do you do money 9
million dollars is not a
little and
and there are  we are also very deeply involved,
to be honest, months-long processes,
so I think they affected us for three or four
years, the first full
round and then you build a
relationship with the contact person, then when
there was the right moment, then
you talk about investment and that
it's true but you were a bit
surprised afterwards when i saw that the
press release we gave from it
then you think to yourself whether
otto frank yes of course you
come from the actually modest
circumstances and we jumped on
that actually still in exactly as
I said when we talk about tabletop
coffee machines then just
do it yourself but of course you have to think big you
have to invest sustainably you have to have
opportunities  they identify where you
can invest all the money
and
then enter it and then it is also very
clear that the best investors and
the compelling power to leave the comfort zone, that is, the entitlement
is always the best and always only and
that's what we want too  if
that leads to the fact that you really develop an
outstanding company we will
almost meet again and
personally now despite
kroner please again and that is
really enriching every time and
learned to try to listen for it
calls you in one of the emails you
ask  how is it going or you have
questions or how g  are you in contact i
had a collaboration then
you can talk to each other and then
you get burned than
that it's not terribly complicated
and and of course we also appreciate a
wheel very much i mean with paypal he
probably founded it innocently than the success
itself and  built up in addition
also really call German speaks
in Germany
speaks German and
really has an extremely sharp
view of these macroeconomic
relationships and that one is
always very happy to
talk about them okay okay because I
remember them  so we need it
very much was a story and
who has now it's also the
display but also we hopefully
most of us know how
during the year we talk from time to time because we do the
weekday stock market podcast
together or active difficult and
various other things again and again
thank goodness
we are very happy about it  and about the
trip yes and try you know
support even if i think the
podcast and not the biggest action is
scandal but at least one of the
customers but hastily done yes there you
can
so today i would say the
biggest business podcast in germany
like  you can trust spotify ranking there
and as such i think i also
do trading culturally relevant i
think it creates a completely different approach
to the topic of the stock market i think the name
says it all because without shares it’s really
difficult because there was also the legendary
appointment as a whole and i had
one  to the other name suggestions then
you said so yes we need
something more now sounds like a
podcast i have to look at the analyzes
podcast if we mixed so that halo
or what is the name of everyone else and
then we
still have et ass simply
no so it is  there was also a cool thing
integrated into the app and several
10,000 people look
at it
and the i every day  is another building block
to inspire people to get involved
with the topic but to
set the mind to take a look in a year
or so often make the next
update and flame in brome 1 1 game
is then there was the next round or it
lasts  it's going to be longer that's going to
happen afterwards none what's going on yes that all
speaks after the federal funding de
well yes that's certainly right
[laughter]
all right well thank you very much and then
say but it means
[applause]
[music]